welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Emma Skye a senior fellow at the
Jackson Institute at the Macmillan
Center where she lectures on Iraq and
Middle East politics she is a British
citizen who has worked at senior levels
on behalf of the US and UK governments
in Iraq Afghanistan and Jerusalem across
the fields of development defense and
diplomacy and with both civilian and
military agencies today we talk with
Professor sky about her new book the
unraveling high hopes and missed
opportunities in Iraq
welcome professor sky thank you let's
begin with an overview of your book tell
us about it the book tells about my
experiences in Iraq I first went through
Iraq in 2003
why was the senior civilian
representative of the coalition in
Kirkuk and it goes through the surge in
2007 when I was a political adviser to
general Odierno then through the
drawdown of US troops and ends in 2014
with the takeover of a third of the
country by the Islamic state I felt and
witnessed so many of these key events
that I felt almost a duty to write about
it and I wanted to honor the efforts of
all those who worked in Iraq and strive
to make the country a better place I
wanted to remember the people who lost
their lives and I wanted to pay tribute
to the country of Iraq it's a country
that I came very much to love so you
have been you were there for more than a
decade and you actually volunteered to
help rebuild Iraq after the fall of the
regime why did you do that well the
British government asked for volunteers
to help rebuild the country it was
supposed to be for three months before
we hand in the country back over to the
Iraqis three months three months it was
supposed to be hmm and I was against the
war and I thought is my chance to go to
Iraq to apologize to Iraqis for the war
to help them rebuild the country I'd
worked for a decade in Israel Palestine
and I felt I had skills to contribute in
conflict mediation and institutional
development okay so in the decade or so
that you were there how would you
categorize your experiences and the time
you spent there it was the most
challenging experience of my life I was
nearly killed a number of times
Wow and people I know lost their lives
there but I grew as a person I made
extraordinary bonds with American
soldiers and I made really great Iraqi
friends tell us about a daily life what
did you do on a daily basis give us some
examples of what it was like for you no
day in Iraq is the same so it's very
difficult to talk about a typical day
because it wasn't a typical day okay but
the morning would start very early
you'll be going to meetings with the US
military where all the events of the
evening the day before were covered then
deciding what was the schedule for the
day and then going out it's often I
would go with general Odierno to visit
troops then we would go and have
meetings with Iraqis right the way
through till 7:00 or 8:00 o'clock and
then at night I would go out and see
more Iraqis were you in the middle of
any kind of gunfire well I'd only been
in Iraq a week when my house was
attacked with me in it so how was it
attack insurgents came to the front door
with rockets mm-hm and the Rockets came
into the house but unfortunately or
fortunately for me they exploded between
the ceiling and the bed where I was
sleeping I was very fortunate that was
in my first week and why did you not run
run run back to England I couldn't now I
couldn't
I really felt I've got to stay and help
rebuild this country had you ever ever
been in anything like that before and in
other countries was that your first
experience with that kind of a situation
well I had worked in Gaza and the West
Bank before so I was used to a difficult
situation but I never experienced
anything like Iraq when I myself could
be a target let alone just in the wrong
place
so you originally you believe that
basically a stable government was on the
brink of happening and then things went
very awry and that opportunity was
squandered what happened you know during
the surge the level of violence in Iraq
decreased dramatically and we and the
Iraqis felt the country's on the right
track it's gonna go in the right
direction
in 2010 the national elections were held
high participation and the results were
very very close very very close
contested results and unfortunately the
US didn't uphold the rights of the
winning bloc to have first go at trying
to form the government instead the
government insisted and said the US
government insisted on keeping the
incumbent Nouri al-maliki in power and
why did they do that do you think I
think because it appeared the easiest
option Obama had campaigned to end the
Iraq war it seemed easier to keep the
incumbent rather than trying to help a
new government be formed with a new
leader and unfortunately Maliki then
went on to follow very sectarian
policies alienated the Sunni population
there were widespread protests and the
Islamic state rose to power so in that
moment when that occurred what was going
on in your head did you know right out
that that would be a terrible decision
yes I did because it meant that people
don't trust the system it's a very new
system people have got to believe that
change comes about through elections
rather through violence if they try
elections and they can't bring about
change then they lose faith in the
system so the people on the ground like
yourself or probably were they not
saying to the US government listen this
is a mistake yes this was a internal
debate and unfortunately those who said
look give the winning block first go it
might not succeed but at least people
could see the elections have been
honored the guy who won the elections
gets first go at trying to form the
government if he fails it goes to the
next candidate okay so unfortunately
then that was the the decline to where
we are today or were their subsequent
mistakes is well made that was the major
mistake because it was very difficult to
recover from that afterwards so today
what you what you think needs to happen
in Iraq for a stable government to
develop I think it's very difficult to
form a stable government in Iraq the
Islamic state needs to be defeated the
sheer militias need to be demobilized
and you've got to push Iran back out of
Iraq and power needs to be decentralized
away from Baghdad so now the province is
more say in their own affairs mm-hmm do
you foresee yourself going back there
and continuing the work that you had
been doing I don't foresee myself going
back to Iraq to work but so I go back on
a regular basis to visit my friends in
Iraq and what is their life like now
given the current situation it depends
it's very different in different parts
of the country in the south where the
majority of the population is shir
there's progress being made people's
standard of living is improving in
Kurdistan there has been good progress
as well but in the Sunni areas of Iraq
this massive population displacement
lots of people have been kicked out of
their homes or fled in fear what do you
think the future holds for Iraq it's
hard to be optimistic Lee speaking it's
hard to be optimistic about the future
of Iraq but it's a land with a great
history it gave the world the written
law
first settled agriculture is where the
Talmud was written Baghdad used to be
capital of culture of the Arab world and
so we have to hope that a new generation
will come that will draw inspiration
from that great history if there's one
thing that you'd like readers to take
from your book a lesson perhaps what
would it be I think the lesson would be
a lesson of common humanity that really
there's much more that unites us than
divides us very good thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
your work thank you very much for more
information about Professor sky and her
book please visit our website at
yale.edu slash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale